Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Pocas personas han influido en pensadores
actuales y en el mundo como Platón.
Un filósofo del siglo XX llegó incluso
a describir a la filosofía occidental
como notas al pie a la obra de Platón.
Platón creó la primera
universidad occidental
y fue profesor de las mentes
más grandes de la Antigua Grecia,
incluyendo a Aristóteles.
Pero, incluso, como uno de los fundadores
de la filosofía, no era perfecto.
Junto con sus grandes ideas,
Platón tuvo algunas ideas que
no resistieron el paso del tiempo.
Este es un breve recorrido por algunas
de sus mejores y peores ideas.
Platón sostuvo que más allá
de nuestro mundo imperfecto
estaba el mundo inmutable
perfecto de las formas.
Las formas son versiones ideales de cosas
y conceptos que vemos a nuestro alrededor.
Sirven como una especie de manual de
instrucciones para nuestro propio mundo.
Flotando en el mundo de las formas
está el árbol ideal,
y el canal ideal de YouTube,
e incluso la justicia ideal
o el amor ideal.
Nuestra propia realidad está compuesta
por copias imperfectas de formas ideales.
Platón sostenía que los filósofos
debían esforzarse por contemplar
y comprender esas formas perfectas
para navegar mejor por
nuestra realidad engañosa.
Si bien puede parecer una tontería,
la desconexión entre el mundo como aparece
y la mayor verdad subyacente
es uno de los problemas
más acuciantes de la filosofía.
Ha sido objeto de miles
de páginas por parte de teólogos,
filósofos,
y guionistas por igual.
Se plantea preguntas como ¿Debemos confiar
en que los sentidos lleguen a la verdad
o en nuestra propia razón?
Para Platón, la respuesta es la razón.
Es la única que nos da, al menos,
el potencial para contemplar las formas.
Pero la razón no siempre permea
para el propio Platón.
Cuando trató de situar a la humanidad
entre los animales,
nos agrupó con las aves.
"Bípedos sin plumas",
fue su designación oficial.
Diógenes el Cínico,
molesto por esta definición,
irrumpió en la clase de Platón
con un pollo desplumado,
anunciando: "He aquí el hombre de Platón".
Pero volvamos a algunas buenas ideas.
Platón es uno de los primeros
teóricos de la política en la historia,
y con Aristóteles, se ve como uno de
los fundadores de la ciencia política.
Llegó a la conclusión de que gobernar
no era diferente de cualquier otro arte,
como alfarero o médico,
y que solo quienes dominaran el arte
estarían en condiciones de conducir.
Gobernar era el arte de
contemplar las formas.
En su República, Platón imaginó una utopía
donde la justicia es el objetivo final.
La ciudad ideal de Platón buscaba un
equilibrio armonioso entre sus partes
y debía ser liderada por un rey filósofo.
Milenios antes de su tiempo,
Platón también razonó que las mujeres
podían gobernar en ese modelo de ciudad.
Por desgracia, Platón era incompatible
con las mujeres
y las comparaba con los niños.
También creía que el útero de la mujer
era un animal vivo
que podría deambular por su cuerpo
y causar enfermedades.
Esta mala idea, también expuesta
por otros contemporáneos de Platón,
influyó tristemente durante cientos
de años en la medicina europea.
Por otra parte, pensó que la sociedad
debía dividirse en tres grupos:
productores,
militares,
y gobernantes, y que
una gran mentira noble debía convencer
a todos a seguir esta estructura.
La mentira noble que propuso
era que todos nacemos con el oro,
la plata, o una mezcla de metal e hierro
en nuestras almas,
que determinan nuestros roles en la vida.
Algunos pensadores han dado crédito
a la idea de la mentira noble
como prototipo de la propaganda
del siglo XX, y el rey
filósofo como fuente de inspiración
para los dictadores que las usan.
¿Deberían unas ideas malas
empañar el estatus de Platón como uno de
los más grandes filósofos de la historia?
¡No!
Platón dio a los líderes y pensadores que
vinieron después un punto de partida.
A través de los siglos,
pudimos probar esas ideas mediante
la escritura y la experiencia,
y aceptamos algunas y rechazamos otras.
Seguimos refinando, modificando,
y editando sus ideas
que se han vuelto pilares
del mundo moderno.